Kamala Harris in the hot seat after
another embarrassing week according to
multiple reports Democrats would rather
roll the dice with an 80-year-old Joe
Biden to nominate our nation's bumbling
Veep Kamala was asked point blank on
whether she's a good fit for 2024.
they don't think that you're the right
person to be on the ticket I think that
it is very important to focus on the
needs of the American people and not
political chatter out of Washington D.C
do you still want to be president
someday
Joe Biden intends has said he intends to
run for re-election as president and I
intend to run with him
as Vice President of the United States
so Democrats don't like her and neither
does the American public if her latest
approval numbers are any indication but
Kamala seems to be in denial about all
of that
why do you think the president has such
low popularity favorable ratings and you
have even less favorable ratings what do
you think that is I see people thanking
the president it's not translating our
Administration
so Kamala thinks she's might be getting
some favorable interview with NBC and
she kind of got punched in the face
right there how do you think she handled
it you know what I'm gonna shock you she
handled that well she was on message she
was on message she was clear she even
she was like with all this tackling and
you know it's not easy to get 61 of the
American public to agree that you're not
doing well at your job okay only 39
thinks that she is and the truth is for
a woman who lived in politics and lived
on a government salary for decades to
not be able to articulate and speak the
way she just did there I mean it's about
time she's got the job of a lifetime the
vice president of the United States and
by the way it took 18 staffers to get
her to this point and one of the ones
who's most impressive is Simone Sanders
I think she could straighten anybody out
she didn't even straighten me out okay
it's impossible maybe not but anyway
um but for two years we watched word
salads come out of her mouth and she did
she did a good job there and and you
know for two years Stephen football
players get media training and they've
done better better than her but I think
in the end that if she's serious about
this job
um you know it may this may benefit her
but the Dems fear uh Joe Biden and they
fear her even more than Biden so we'll
see well you did bring up a word salad
so I would be remiss if I just didn't
play this what's up
we will maintain the perspective that we
have in terms of what should be the
relationship between China and the
United States
that is not going to change but surely
and certainly that balloon was not
helpful which is why we shot it down
okay
okay Jessica make sense of that for us
please
China did a bad thing we still need to
have a relationship China did a
not-helpful thing
translation is China did a really bad
thing okay
nothing is going to change in terms of
the fact that we know that we have to
work with China but we haven't forgotten
the fact that they did a bad thing and
I'd like to speak to some people she's
at the Munich security conference and
there are some people there that she's
going to have a word or two with about
it and compared to previous like
remember the clip with the passage of
time but this it was a great interview
you're completely right and Andrea
Mitchell did not pull any punches with
her went straight at her said what's
going on with the popularity what's
going on with the agenda and she's
completely right to first of all stand
in line she's second right saying I
support Joe Biden but we talked about
this a couple weeks ago when everyone
said oh his dismal polling numbers they
were dismal at the midterms and the
Democrats performed better than anybody
expected you paid a lot of money
to me and Geraldo no it wasn't any kind
of money for me
[Laughter]
a red wave I didn't see it just say that
tell me I thought it was going to be
wavier so um Mitchell kind of went right
at her do you think as these two ladies
they say is she improving well listen I
will give Andrea a lot of credit for
doing this interview but she's in the
Washington bubble where I live and
operate and work and these are the kind
of stories this is Politico it said this
week high-level Democrats rallying to
President Biden's reelection not because
they think it's in the best interest of
the country to have an 82 year old start
a second term but because they fear the
potential alternative the nomination of
Kamala Harris an election of Donald
Trump there are stories all over the
place in Washington these don't just
happen there have been leaks after leaks
plants after plants of people who have
been going after Kamala Harris from the
inside of the Democrat Party so they
have created this situation and now
they're saying we really want Biden
because we don't think Kamala Harris can
beat Trump and they think that anyone
can be former president Trump so they've
created this situation and they're going
to have to deal with it and the bar is
so low with Kamala I mean we're all now
I was saying oh she did a good job
because she could speak strung a
sentence or two together yes well it's
Lowered Expectations right which is why
all she has to do I mean if she were to
uh you know Saint Joe Biden did step
aside and she were to run she would be
judged on her past performance and all
she has to do is not burst into laughing
every five seconds and everyone's gonna
think she's great but I thought that
interview was creepy it's just that well
the creepy and that it was that nice
tone she was like nobody likes you why
is that yeah she had this kind of gentle
quality but she was giving her all these
uh tough questions uh but Kamala yeah
she's terrible uh Joe Biden terrible but
it doesn't really matter because with
Democrats as you know I remember Mitt
Romney famously said that 47 of the
country is going to vote for you no
matter what that's how you come in
fetterman you remember he opened the
debate saying good night everybody
and he still won so obviously it doesn't
matter if you are a candidate that is
impaired Joe Biden fetterman Kamala you
know what we should just start running
impaired people because then the bar is
so low and then everybody feels sorry
for you and you got your 47 percent that
was the argument about Donald is what
your state performance is that we had
lowered the bar that when he strung
together a few sentences it was some
huge Victory John Federman had had a
catastrophic Stroke by the way when that
happened and he just had to check into
the hospital with clinical depression
and I don't think we should be using him
as any conversation I feel bad for the
city the citizens of Pennsylvania that's
it that's yours think of the voters
we're not here for the politicians
everybody step aside
all right
thank you thank you thank you no thank
you no thank you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else